Speaker 1: We have the resurgence of the Matt
Gates story.
Now, many of you wrote to me two weeks ago,
last week, maybe even three weeks ago, saying,
David, what on earth happened to that Matt
Gates investigation?
We learned that a Republican congressman from
Florida, Matt Gates, has been under investigation
possibly for child sex trafficking.
He may have paid underage girls for sex.
He may have actually paid to transmit them
from one state to another.
There's all this stuff blowing up with Matt
Gates.
But then the story just kind of disappeared.
And my view two weeks ago, my view last week
was it's going to come back.
There have been distractions because of other
things that have been going on, the Joe Biden
address to a joint session of Congress, et
cetera, et cetera, all of these other things.
The story is now coming back.
And we are now learning that federal investigators,
as reported by the week, are pushing for the
cooperation of two key witnesses in investigating
Matthew Gates, including an ex-girlfriend
of Matt Gates.
When the investigators talked to the ex-girlfriend,
it's rarely good.
If the ex-girlfriend cooperates, it's very,
very bad for Matt Gates and investigators
are looking for cooperation from an ex-girlfriend
who was actually an intern on Capitol Hill.
I don't think many of us would be shocked
by that.
And they are also looking for formal cooperation
from that.
Joel Greenberg, he's the former county tax
collector in Florida who we now have reason
to believe because of a letter he wrote that
Greenberg himself introduced Matt Gates to
underage girls.
This is all potentially disastrous for Matt
Gates.
The investigation in part is over whether
Gates had sex with a 17 year old girl and
violated federal sex trafficking laws.
He's denied wrongdoing.
The denials are essentially meaningless at
this point.
And the former girlfriend that investigators
are seeking cooperation from reportedly joined
Gates in 2018 on a trip to the Bahamas, which
has become a big focus of the investigation.
She was, quote, involved in some financial
transactions that the FBI has obtained and
is, quote, believed to have knowledge of drug
use and arrangements with women.
This is potentially very bad for Matt Gates.
We expected that as things settled back down
in the U.S., we would get back to the Gates
story.
And indeed, the news is starting to flow on
that and consider the insanity.
To go back to our story about the cancelation
of Republican Congresswoman Liz Cheney, who's
been voted out of her leadership role because
she said, hey, guys, Trump lost essentially.
Look at how the Republican Party has been
almost silent on the Gates fiasco, but are
overly zealous to punish Liz Cheney merely
for saying, yeah, Biden won.
Consider that incredible hypocrisy.
And it's not just that they claim to be against
council culture, but they regularly try to
console people.
They also regularly, regularly are going after
the wrong people.
And the Gates Cheney thing is exhibit A and
whether Matt Gates will be charged, we still
don't know.
There's a lot of unknowns here, but it is
not looking particularly good